[music]
cut down water or water
plibber life and after all, san nak archers
barlyk
julivi tags and
boil
[music]
subal from
this
[music]
song we became and on the surf we became weak exactly
to the type of type of india about
I want input  tower its attic are you ready for
me to have a gift
for .
not salty
in communication salty and
[music]
on physical
majorica and
affairs genesher marvel
[music]
at once on the oceans and enemies will
allow shops for october and exhalation we
finalized before
[music]
price figures
gelenina james
his business
[music]
[  music]
[applause]
now steel up from
men to the tape
my my
son mother my
little rusi for us senor again
boy ms
office
excel and
usually this is not an end in itself .
now which can be there
was in the fog I tried to
pillow
not grandmother
grandmother but
[music]
in the cinema the
tragedy took away and only you
so woman that you learned from the most
important thing for me that our country
Ukraine is a good country yes we have a
lack of money  our population
may not have such a developed economy
one people the mentality of people, as it were, well, I
understood the officer that we have good people
living people who help each other
this example, for example, it’s the loss of the
phone that they returned this phone and
[music]
first when he arrived  people
were wary of him, and after they
watched the news about him, well, the purpose of
his arrival was to see how
Ukrainian people live and they opened up for him,
they go,
stop, greet him,
offer him to come to them, guests to drink
tea, meet him on, but how  ask
him questions
as if for me it left a good
impression
we ride on
delivered him from 5 baht msd
viking frail stands noise souls deep forest
a  nd
animated
and
[music]
organ as
if the voices of the gage
open as my mistakes the rest for
sex Ahsoka was
[music]
it is clear that not all people reacted
because we watched the comments
treated this with understanding and
do not condemn anyone but this  our
upbringing of our children and we believe that
this is so right as parents, that is,
we have the right to it they will be ready for the
difficulties of their future adult
life they will know that something can be
grown on the earth, something can be fed
from an animal that it can then be  will
eat, that is, not be afraid to slaughter the
same goose and chicken for years, we believe that
our children grow better than we
taught how to go to the store and
buy from
sellers and and
chocolates with a banana
[music]
spmd
[music  ]
and
in terms of ulya sync teacher
snipe to 6 and
that the
dixens of
power is locked making it all as in the world
elac of this scheme
smartphone aldo finish spoons of water marilla
knock
the 1st
canteen and blockade and hash  flare bine
jungarik me a corner of switzerland and
made a square not
syphilis from a birch flows and a
spile with the
army team amber full
from the ashes
[music]
and
so we learned something from peter
now looked looked from the side and
at the family
everyday what happens to us
turned out to be  it’s not so everyday that
from the outside it’s all fun
[laughter]
[music] the
last open from 20 mori mori razmikovich
and
number 7 to
8 liked well when it just started,
otherwise it’s given over in the donbass, we came here to
stepenko with the whole family, we don’t have  there was no
money or nothing there were just things that is, I
came here about loot these stones
brought home and made at home smear
this light and market and galaxy core
alexander a major force
Frolov’s affairs
this is washing away for a
break
in the chain to
[music]
what I  he was taught
that he is capable of more than he
imagined, that is, he crossed for
some
years the steps of his well, his
inner strength of the male spirit, he
crossed having eaten the same fly, for example
[music]
not everyone is capable of  but it’s like that, he
just stepped over himself, he became stronger
, he also saw with his own eyes that
you can cope with many problems
simply because the governors don’t want to be one whole
college together, the
deputies don’t want to continue for 20 bucks
like an array and a moment and again
avoid mafs and blocks
or in the forehead  and
for booth with
cleared force then they do
come hall sens
[music]
winners are you have a camp for mass
present
[music]
continuous
helium
in addition and
mafia well, that's the comfort of such flowers acts of an
angel and on himself ten gameplay  knocked out
playmates and dance a walk
through the court of cold water until peter
wants to do something all the time if he sees that I'm
doing something right after it comes picks up a
shovel picks up all these buckets you
tear out your hands wants to try what we
do as a man for 6 weeks not
sat out never your remember
participated from morning to evening in the life of
abuse
I myself and myself stand
independent
independent can I can there
[applause] there
were five chu  vstv and
mike keenen orxan deniz &
peter soon there
across the line
online she city shane sex
exiga fyodor
i
think
he is a cheerful open person he makes
contact like he was hiding nothing from
his personal life i hide nothing from
his personal life but this  communication, as it were,
will be missed communication
hit come here through this for a well
[laughter]
well, plus I'm a cheerful person in my own right
I like to laugh well, as if with him,
but he responds very well to humor to
jokes
that
Ukraine taught even if he  he doesn’t understand something,
he supports it, but this is a cheerful
mood, and even if he sees that she
falls from someone, he tries to raise
as much as he can
[music]
we will pray for the girls
on
[music]
3 6 9
this is him and
I will
c and family
a pure white
president inherent 137 women.
[music]
but not
holy grief
if we
sara 30
min m without eating
[music] it
will be like back
[music]
valeriy
we will wait for the business of the
palm of your hand
and on you you come I will give out
[music]
making
arrived and the chair mark  uterus
hello
[music]
out of sight will
all peter must wear well
[music]
jog
I love you what
I love raw
hello san francisco
before
[music]
whole
book 5
final